this week we're talking about persistent
disk bigquery and s AP apps and Auto ml
translation I'm Jen and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news when it comes to
managing block storage data protection
in the cloud
everyone makes trade-offs based on their
situation to make sure you're ready with
the backup and recovery plan that your
situation needs we've got a variety of
features in persistent disk features
like snapshot locality scheduled
snapshots and automatic replication
between zones for regional persistent
disk bigquery is a dream come true for
massive datasets and machine learning
models and now we're making complex
tasks like data quality checking part of
bigquery with the beta launch of
scripting and stored procedures before
steps had to be run manually but now you
can script directly in bigquery
hello local variables and even save your
script as a stored procedure which you
can share and run again next month
building great cloud solutions is more
than building your perfect enterprise
data warehouse companies rely on
internal data systems to operate systems
like ASAP apps and often those systems
need to work with your cloud solutions
to discover new insights so we've got an
integration guide that will walk you
through data replication from s ap
applications to Google bigquery with
existing tooling our translation API got
a series of updates this week most
notably Auto ml translation is now
generally available so anyone can build
domain-specific translation into their
workflows translate your corporate lingo
with the use of a glossary or three
which you can apply manually or
automatically talk about synergy if you
want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link how many thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you